Mick Mulvaney spends the day on the
hotseat president Trump sends the g7 to
his own resort and our journalism in
bettors set their sights on Facebook I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
Wow endless numbers of things to get to
today we're going to jump in in just one
second first the Ben Shapiro show is
sponsored by Express VPN protect your
online privacy today had expressed it
VPN calm it's like my mobile we love our
friends over expressed with VPN okay so
the big news of the day all surrounds
Mick Mulvaney before we get into it
first we have to note the passing of
Elijah Cummings long time a
congressperson
from Washington DC / Baltimore obviously
according to the Associated Press
Maryland representative Elijah Cummings
a sharecroppers son who rose to become a
civil rights champion and the chairman
of one of the US House committees
leading an impeachment inquiry of
President Trump died Thursday of
complications from long-standing health
problems he was 68 years old he was a
formidable orator who advocated for the
poor and his black majority district
according to the Associated Press you
don't have to like Elijah Cummings his
politics to understand that he was good
at the game and not only that that he
was actually according to virtually
every Republican who worked with him
somebody who operated with a high level
of honor inside his own chamber there's
a lot of bipartisan respect for Elijah
Cummings so all the best to his wife and
family obviously condolences to
everybody who knew Elijah Cummings trey
Gowdy made a really nice statement on
Twitter about Elijah Cummings he said he
Elijah Cummings was one of the most
powerful beautiful and compelling voices
in American politics the power and the
beauty came from his authenticity his
conviction the sincerity with which he
held his beliefs we rarely agreed on
political matters we never had a cross
word outside of a committee room he had
a unique ability to separate the
personal from the work the story of
Elijah's life would benefit everyone
regardless of political ideation the
obstacles of barriers and roadblocks he
overcame and the external and sometimes
internal doubt that whispered in the ear
of a young Elijah Cummings he beat it
all he beat the odds
he beat the low expectations of that
former school employee who told you
Elijah to abandon the dream of being a
lawyer that he would never become a
lawyer to settle for a job with his
hands and not his mind he lied you loved
telling that story because that school
employee wound up being Elijah's first
client as a lawyer we live in an age
where we see people on TV a couple of
times and we think we know them and what
they are about
it is truly Lodge was a proud
progressive with the booming melodious
voice who found himself in the middle of
the most major political stories of over
the past decade it is inescapable that
be part of his legacy but his legacy
also includes the path he took to become
one of the most powerful political
figures of his time
it is a
have filled with pain prejudice
obstacles and doubt that he refused to
let stop him
his legacy is perseverance his legacy is
fighting through the pain his legacy is
making sure there were fewer obstacles
for the next Elijah Cummings his legacy
to me above else was above all else was
his faith a faith in God that is being
awarded today with no more fights no
more battles and no more pain so good
for nice statement by trey gowdy
and regardless of your political
affiliation when people in public
service pass away and they are in and
they are well respected across the
political out it's worthy of taking a
moment okay so the big news of the day
obviously surrounds the statements of
president Trump's acting chief of staff
Mick Mulvaney who also is the head of
the Office of Management and Budget has
an enormous amount of power and
influence inside the Trump
administration and is seen by many as
the guy whose can Trump's hatchet man on
the inside we will get to what Mick
Mulvaney said in just one second first
of all we have to say how many different
types of cars are there on the road like
you're listening to this it's quite
possible you're listening to this in
your car look out the window and you
will see there are a bevy of different
types of cars on the road do you really
think that the local auto parts store
has the parts that you specifically need
for your car the chances are pretty low
and that is why God made the interwebs
the interwebs are there so that you can
actually have the precise part that you
require at a price that you can afford
this is where Rock Auto calm comes in
rockauto.com is a family business
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers they have everything from
engine control modules and brake parts
to tail lamps motor oil even new carpet
whether it's for your classic or your
daily driver get everything you need and
a few easy clicks delivered directly to
your door the rockauto.com catalog is
super easy to navigate quickly see all
the parts available for your vehicle and
filter by brands and specifications and
prices as well invest of all the prices
of rockauto.com they're always reliably
low and the same for professionals and
do-it-yourselfers they've got great
selection low prices and the parts that
your car needs Rock Auto comm go-to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck and
right Shapiro's in there how did you
hear about a spot so they know we sent
you that helps us it also helps them
check that out at rockauto.com
and right Shapiro's in there how did you
hear about us box okay so the big story
over the course of yesterday was Mick
Mulvaney
president Trump's acting chief of staff
coming out and saying a bevy of things
about Ukraine so let's go through the
things that Mick Mulvaney actually said
about Ukraine because I think some of
them are some of them are true and some
of them are badly stated and some of
them are being misconstrued and some of
them make real trouble for president
Trump so here's what Mick Mulvaney had
to say about Ukrainian who specifically
asked whether aid to Ukraine was tied to
Ukraine investigating the 2016 election
and here's what Mick Mulvaney had to say
did he also mentioned to me and past the
the the the corruption related to the
DNC server absolutely no question about
that but that's it that's why we held up
the money we look back to what happened
in 2016 certainly was was part of the
thing that he was worried about in
corruption with that nation and that is
absolutely yeah which ultimately then
float Mulvaney's saying yes there was a
quid pro quo we did hold off the
military aid in order to pressure the
Ukrainians to look into the 2016
election but we didn't do the quid pro
quo about investigation of the Biden's
that's a significant walk back you just
described is a quid pro quo it is
funding will not flow unless the
investigation into the into the
democratic server happened as well we do
we do that all the time with foreign
policy okay no people are construing
this as he said there was a quid pro quo
that is impeachable now as I've said all
along the problem here is quid pro quo
what I've also said all along is that it
depends what the quid pro quo is for so
for example we know that three
Democratic senators actually wrote the
administration in Ukraine just last year
and said to them we want to withhold
your aid unless you are willing to fully
cooperate with the Muller investigation
so that would be a quid pro quo would it
not I mean that is a quid pro quo in
other words there are strings attached
to American aid the question is whether
the strings attached are overtly about
getting a political opponent remember
where this story started he can see how
the story is now morphing right so the
story started with the accusation that
Donald Trump specifically said to
Ukraine you will not get your aid unless
you investigate your Biden now the media
are shifting this into well it's just as
bad if Trump said you won't get your
unless you investigate Ukrainian
interference in the 2016 election no
that's it that's not the same thing
that's not that the United States and
the people of the United States do have
a legitimate interest in finding out
about foreign interference in the 2016
election and I'm having a hard time
frankly understanding how folks on the
Left don't get this considering that
they just spent two years investigating
with taxpayer dollars Russian
interference in an American election and
that members of the US Congress who are
Democrats were threatening to withhold
aid from Ukraine if they didn't help
with that specific investigation about
the 2016 election so in other words if
you withhold aid to Ukraine because they
won't help Democrats investigate Muller
that's okay
if you won't hand over aid to Ukraine
unless they investigate Ukraine's
meddling that helped Hillary Clinton
then it's very bad in a quid pro quo I
don't understand how these both can be
simultaneously true that does not make
any moral sense at all now that's not
really war Mulvaney slipped up so
everybody is jumping on the fact that he
was asked specifically about quid pro
quo and then he sort of said yeah we do
that all the time to mean that he is
saying that there's a quid pro quo
American taxpayer money to help
President Trump politically and that's
not what he said and when you're talking
about a quid pro quo that matters you
have to be talking about something that
you cannot use American taxpayer money
to do if you look the accusation about
Joe Biden for example is an accusation
that Joe Biden used American taxpayer
dollars right what billion dollars in
loan guarantees Ukraine in order to
benefit himself and his son hunter Biden
personally that's the accusation
president Trump is making Biden's
defenses no when I said that there was a
quid pro quo what I meant is that I'm
withholding 1 billion dollars in loan
guarantees specifically until Ukraine
cleans up its act with regard to
corruption and the Obama administration
was pressuring in early 2016 and
throughout 2016 in fact pressuring the
Ukrainian government to clean up on
corruption and that involved
investigating people like Paul Amana
Ford who ended up as Trump's campaign
chief of staff so was that wrong of the
Obama administration so they did they
violate the law there was that a quid
pro quo in the sense that everybody is
talking about an impeachable offense the
answer is no right now Mulvaney phrased
all of this in like the stupidest
possible way and in just one second I'm
going to read you the full context of
his comments and
what I think he was trying to say but
let's be real about this
he was very awkward in how he said it
and he created more nightmares and more
headaches for President Trump the
president's legal team today is walking
away from Mulvaney saying listen we
didn't vet that press conference we have
no idea what that guy was saying Sean
Hannity who of course is a big defender
of the President on virtually every
topic he came out and he was ripping
into Mulvaney so even mo they even
Trump's biggest defenders are unhappy
with what with what Mulvaney said but
I'm pretty sure that the headlines are
not matching what Mulvaney actually said
right the headlines today are all about
how Mick Mulvaney basically said sure we
do quid pro quos all the time what he
was saying is that there are strings
attached to American foreign policy aid
that of course has always been true and
he's correct about that it's just he
phrased it in the worst possible way
because maybe she's not that good at
this again the stupidity more than
malice explanation tends to hold true
for virtually everything people make
mistakes people say dumb things
particularly in the political realm but
we'll explain word for word what he said
and then you can make your own judgment
I'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about Tommy John
underwear so there is one brand of
underwear that is better than any other
undergarments comfortable stuff we're
talking about Tommy John Tommy John
stuff is fantastic how do I know because
it graces might very took us this very
moment Tommy John doesn't just claim to
be the most comfortable underwear on the
planet they actually have the stats to
back it up like they have 7 million
pairs of Tommy John underwear they've
sold with 96% of their customers rating
them four stars or greater with Tommy
John's revolutionary underwear the legs
never ride up the waist bands never roll
down Tommy John is more than just
underwear they've got 750 products
online such as supersoft loungewear polo
shirts and apparel and dudes here's
something for the ladies in your life
after two years and countless hours of
obsessing over every little detail Tommy
John is proud to introduce the most
comfortable bras on the planet if you
prefer to shop in stores you can find
them online
you know that find them in over 1,200
retail locations across the country
including Nordstrom stores nationwide
Tommy John no adjustment needed my wife
where's Tommy John as well she loves it
Tommy John is just fantastic hurry over
to Tommy John comm slash Ben right now
to get 20% off your first order that's
Tommy John comm slash Ben for 20% off
Tommy John comm slash Ben you don't shy
away from spending a little extra money
on like a nice pair of pants why would
you shy away from spending a little
money
on something that is going to grace your
butt every single way go check them out
over at Tommy John comm slash Ben and
get 20% off your first order when you
use that address Tommy John comm slash
Ben okay so here is what Mick Mulvaney
actually had to say
word for word so he was asked quote that
a man for an investigation into the
Democrats was part of the reason that
Trump ordered to withhold funding to
Ukraine and Mulvaney said they look back
to what happened in 2016 certainly was
part of the thing that he was worried
about in corruption with that nation and
that is absolutely appropriate okay
that's again that's fair the Obama
administration withheld aids Ukraine
unless they were willing to root out
corruption by looking into people like
Paul Manafort even though Paul Manafort
was working with the Trump campaign at
the time a Hillary Clinton was
coordinating with the Ukrainian
government to receive dirt on President
Trump that was not illegal it was bad
but it was not illegal the Democratic
senators in the last year wrote a letter
to the to the government of Ukraine
saying help out with the Muller
investigation or your aid is gonna go
bye-bye
that's what Mulaney is saying so the the
reporter then said withholding the
funding and Mulvaney said yeah which
alternately then flowed by the way there
was a report that we were worried that
the money wouldn't if we didn't pay out
the money it would be illegal okay it
would be unlawful so he so that is the
power of Mulvaney is starting to look
weird right like this is where Mulvaney
starts blurring the lines and things get
very weird if you were making the claim
that we are allowed to withhold funding
based on investigation of things that
are of importance to the American public
including foreign interference in the
2016 election even badly based
information about foreign interference
in the 2016 election right this is my
theory and I think it is the most
plausible theory by a long shot and that
is that Rudy Giuliani was being fed bad
information by Ukrainian actors he was
feeding that to President Trump
President Trump was putting that into
his mind and churning out a one-note
card statement on Ukraine and that's all
he really was thinking about in Ukraine
that was corruption DNC server 2016
maria ivanna lately they like it
all comes out as a ball of good from
President Trump and then Mulvaney
interprets that as we're fighting
corruption by withholding aid and I
think that's really what happened here
it may be bad information it may be
information that is wrong or incorrect
all of that may very well be true
that does not mean that it's a quid pro
quo for quote-unquote political purposes
when Mulvaney says if we didn't pay out
the money it would be illegal it would
be unlawful based on what like that's
undercutting your own argument if his
argument is we could withhold the aid in
order to achieve the fighting of
corruption which included investigating
for example the DNC server again based
on bad information if that is Mulvaney's
argument then what is he talking about
it would be illegal if we didn't allow
the money to flow and then he was asked
what you just described as a quid pro
quo it is funding will not flow unless
the investigation into the democratic
server happened as well and Mulvaney
said we do that all the time with
foreign policy we were holding up money
at the same time for the northern
triangle countries we were holding up
bait at the northern triangle countries
so they would change their policies and
immigration so what he's saying there
right people are taking the we do quid
pro quos all the time with foreign
policy to mean we do political quid pro
quos that benefit the president all the
time with foreign policy that is not
what he said
right the context is we do stuff that is
quid pro quos with foreign governments
based on foreign aid which of course is
exactly true and then they take out of
context this other line that Mulvaney
says where he says and I have news for
everybody get over it there's gonna be
political influence in foreign policy he
doesn't mean that
get over it the Ukrainians are going to
influence American foreign policy in the
election or the Russians are going to
election what he means by that is that
we are going to attach strings to
foreign policy and he phrases that in
the worst possible way because everyone
is a dope here's the important part
right remember this entire debacle began
with the accusation that it was about
Biden that the quid pro quo is about
Biden don't forget that that's what this
whole thing was about this whole thing
the headlines were Trump ordered Ukraine
aid withheld unless Ukraine went and got
Biden that's what the entire headline
was and just like the Malheur
investigation morphed from a trump
Russia
2016 election interference investigation
into Trump obstruction of justice he
hates robert muller why did he fire the
acting FBI director it morphed really
quickly this one is already morphing so
just notice the moving of the goalposts
and move from the quid pro quo is about
Biden to the quid pro quo is about
corruption in Ukraine well if the quid
pro quo is about corruption in Ukraine
that is not illegal quid pro quo that's
not even really out of the line of kind
of normalcy the only thing that's
out of the line of normalcy is that
Trump's standard of corruption in
Ukraine seems to be based upon bad
information fed to him by Rudy Guiliani
who's running around with a bunch of
nefarious characters from Ukraine while
being paid half a million dollars here
is the key exchange that people are
ignoring of course the question from a
reporter was on the call the President
did ask about investigating the Biden's
are you saying the money that was held
up that had nothing to do with the
Biden's Mohini said no the money he'll
have had absolutely nothing to do with
Biden that was the point I was making to
you and then the reporter said you're
drawing the distinction you're saying it
would be wrong to hold up money for the
Biden's well then he said there were
three factors I was involved with the
process by which the money was held up
temporarily okay three issues the
corruption in the country whether or not
other countries were participating in
support of Ukraine and whether or not
they were cooperating in an ongoing
investigation with our Department of
Justice that's completely legitimate
that is completely legitimate what he is
saying there is not wrong right if
there's an ongoing investigation into
2016 election interference by Ukrainian
government officials working with
Hillary Clinton for example that is not
wrong to withhold aid until Ukraine
helps with that investigation that's not
Obama did it these Democratic senators
did it it is not inappropriate it is not
wrong and then the reporter said you
just said you were involved in the
process in which the money was held up
temporarily you name three issues and
the corruption in the country whether or
not the country would look they were
assisting with an ongoing investigation
of corruption how is that not an
establishment of an exchange of a quid
pro quo and Mulvaney said those are the
terms you used I mean go look at what
Gordon's someone said today in his
testimony it was that I think in his
opening statement he said something
along the lines of they were trying to
get deliverable and the deliverable is a
statement by Ukraine about how they were
going to deal with corruption okay go
read his testimony if you haven't
already and what he says is and he's
right
this is absolutely ordinary course of
business this is what you do when you
have someone come to the White House
when you either arrange a visit for the
president you have a phone call with the
president a lot of times we use that as
an opportunity to get them to make a
statement of their policy or announce
something they're gonna do it's one of
the reasons we can't you know sort of
announced that he's on the phone call or
at the meeting this is the ordinary
course of foreign policy there's a
people again are taking him Mulvaney not
shying away from the phrase quid pro quo
to ignore what kind of quid pro quo he
is talking about hey if I go down to the
local grocery
store and I hand a person money in
exchange for bread that is a quid pro
quo to market transaction if I walk down
to the local slum corner and I hand a
man money in exchange for cocaine that
is also a free transaction it is not the
same kind of transaction right both of
those are quid pro quos one of them is
illegal and one of them is fully within
ordinary course of business withholding
aid in order to achieve certain foreign
policy objectives is in fact the way
that business is done on foreign policy
and that that is a hundred percent right
but the question is whether this was
done in order to get Biden again it's
amazing how Biden has sort of slipped
away from the conversation notice how it
slipped away slipped away
okay well the White House is reacting to
all of this the DOJ reacting to all
Democrats reacting to all this we'll get
to that in just one second first let's
talk about protecting your online
information expressvpn is an app I use
to stay secure online why should you
care about encrypting your data well
it's often easy for a hacker to bypass
Wi-Fi security and steal your
information by exploiting flaws like
crack that would be crack with a K in
case you actually want to Google it it's
very easy for people who know what
they're doing to grab your data and once
they have your data they can use it for
any purpose they want to use it for they
can steal your credit card information
they can take your data and they can
sell it to third-party vendors it's hard
to know whether your device or network
is vulnerable if you ever use Wi-Fi at a
hotel or a shopping mall you're sending
data over an open network meaning no
encryption at all the best way to ensure
that all of your data is encrypted and
can't be read by hackers is to use
Express VPN all you need to do is
download the Express VPN app on your
computer or smartphone you tap one
button to secure 100% of your network
data and then you can use the internet
just the way you normally would Express
VPN is incredibly reliable it's the
fastest VPN service I've tried they're
also rated the world's number one VPN
provider by review sites like tech radar
and sina expressvpn takes privacy and
security to the next level go check them
out right now expressvpn comm slash been
for three extra months free with a
one-year package there's a reason I
trust expressvpn you should to protect
your internet today with the VPN I trust
to keep my data safe go to expressvpn
comm slash Ben to get started okay so
the Democrats are reacting to this Adam
Schiff who's already ready for
impeachment I mean he didn't need this
he now says that Mulvaney did something
super duper duper wrong he says I think
mr. Mulvaney acknowledgment means that
things have gone from very very bad you
much much worse
- mirrored when asked how Mulvaney's
comments would affect the pace of the
houses impeachment inquiry so in other
words Democrats are going to say that
things just got worse even though
basically in reality what Mulvaney said
basically confirmed what the Trump
administration was already saying Schiff
said the idea that vital military
systems would be withheld for such a
patently political reason for the reason
of serving the president's reelection
campaign is a phenomenal breach of the
president's duty to defend our national
security but Mulvaney never said that
and Mulvaney never said that the
military aid was being withheld in order
to help trump politically that miss read
of that one line where he says there is
political influence in foreign policy he
didn't mean that this was meant to help
trump and boost Trump for 2020 he meant
there are strings attached to foreign
policy dollars and is pretty obvious
from the context that that's exactly
what he meant and so Mulvaney is already
walking this thing back so the again
people people are picking on this one
line where I said I have news for
everybody get over it there's going to
be a political influence in foreign
policy that's going to happen elections
have consequences
Mulvaney tonight any aid again was
withheld to pressure Ukraine into going
after Biden so Mulvaney is now saying
that his remarks were misconstrued which
by the way they were right he issued his
statement after the president's outside
legal counsel tried to distance itself
from Mulvaney's earlier comments at a
press briefings at a press briefing
Mulvaney now says there was no quid pro
quo between ukrainian military aid and
that country's willingness to
investigate the 2016 US election now
this is where you get into the stupidity
of politics well then you should say
well yeah of course we were yes we were
withholding military aid unless they
showed willingness to investigate their
own interference in the 2016 election
because if that's not it like really if
what he's saying now is not true then
it's going to look like he was lying
right they're gonna call him to testify
now because he was involved in this
process and he's gonna have to testify
one way or another and so either he was
lying then or he's lying now right he's
getting himself in trouble the truth is
the truth is that of course military aid
was withheld in order to investigate the
2016 election Trump said so on the call
right now so was that stuff was
basically said on the call not the
military aid part but that he wanted the
2016 election interference investigated
there's nothing wrong with that
heimo vanie adds the term never told him
withhold money until the Ukrainians took
action
related to a server Democrats used in
the 2016 election
an earlier briefing Mulvaney had
directly cited questions about the DNC
server as a reason that money for
Ukraine was being held up okay well
again the the questions about Trump's
bizarre questions about whether the DNC
server is being held in Ukraine which we
talked about on the show yesterday that
is founded in bad logic and bad evidence
and Rudy Giuliani being an idiot but
withholding aid because you got bad
information is not the same thing as
withholding aid for political game it's
not quite the same thing because let's
say for the sake of argument that this
weren't a crazy theory and that the DNC
DNC server was in fact being held in
Ukraine and demonstrated as Trump seems
to think bizarrely that Russia did not
hack into the DNC server Ukraine did
wouldn't that be of relevance to the
American people I mean we just spent two
years investigating whether or not the
Russians were behind the 2016 election
interference so who was Ukraine instead
that seems like that would be relevant
now as I say I think it's an idiotic
theory I don't think there's any
evidence to back it but if that's what's
going on in trumps head and that's not
necessarily about Trump's political gain
it's much more about who interfered in
the 2016 election we just spent two
years investigating this and pressuring
Ukraine to cooperate a lawyer for Trump
is trying to distance the president's
legal team from Mulvaney Trump's
personal attorney Jay Sekulow issued a
one-sentence statement that said the
president's legal counsel was not
involved in acting chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney press briefing now again that
ain't gonna it ain't gonna fly it's not
gonna fly I'm sorry like Mulvaney has a
defense here and his defense is exactly
what I'm saying because I'm pretty sure
that's what he was saying and Trump's
legal team running away from him and now
saying well you know he didn't clear his
stuff with us it makes it sound like
what Mulvaney actually admitted to was
the crime
like what Mulvaney admitted to was the
impeachable offense which means they
call him on the carpet they ask him
about what he said and then they impeach
on that basis so the reactions who
Mulvaney for Trump is actually as bad or
worse than what Mulvaney actually said
in terms of the impeachment process and
you can listen to the media coverage
which is really not honest toluse Ola
bonito of the Washington Post says
Mulvaney's retort to the charges that
that Trump abuses office for personal
political gain
a three word mantra that now forms the
central theme of the White House
impeachment response get over it
Mulvaney embraced a classic trumpian
tactic saying the quiet and potentially
illegal part out loud that strategy with
regard to Ukraine came in for withering
criticism and for Mulvaney's appearance
he later tried to walk back his comments
in a statement late Thursday Mulvaney
denied the quid pro quo he'd previously
defended as appropriate and normal well
no he said that he said in the press
conference the quid pro quo wasn't about
Biden the only thing that he reversed
himself on was the DNC server part and
I'm not sure why he reversed himself on
it considering that it's obviously true
but it's obviously true that Trump said
we want to withhold military aid and/or
a presidential meeting until the
Ukrainians get to the bottom of
corruption which includes an
investigation into this DNC server and
2016 election interference question
again for the thousandth time based on
bad information but not based on
necessarily 20/20 election prospects or
political malice so this is how it's
being painted now that wasn't even
honestly that wasn't even the worst part
of this press conference can the worst
part of the press conference as we will
see is Mulvaney's comments about
President Trump directing the g7 to be
held at the at the Trump Doral resort
they're like why is that even hammer why
why why okay we'll get to that in just
one second first last week China
devalued its currency and the markets
tanked one consequence was that Bitcoin
prices rose in times of chaos and
uncertainty people tend to look for
alternative methods of investment that
are not subject to the whims of central
governments messing around with the
currency instead people are investing in
Bitcoin in the same way that they would
invest in precious metals because
Bitcoin effectively speaking is a
product that is created with blockchain
that creates a scarcity that cannot be
hacked by central governments and
manipulated by central governments well
if you are considering getting into the
crypto market you should use eToro eToro
is smart crypto trading made easy eToro
social trading platform has over 11
million traders and facilitates over 1
trillion dollars in trading volume per
year globally you can access the world's
best crypto currencies they have 15
different coins available and got low
and transparent fees you can try before
you trade with a virtual portfolio with
a $100,000 budget never miss a trading
trend with charts and pricing alerts
they make it super easy sign up today at
each
komm slash Shapiro that's eToro comm
slash apparel I love that you can really
try it out before you even put your own
money in so you can see how the system
works go check them out at eToro comm
slash apparel ET oro comm slash shapiro
ok so the worst moment of this presser
was not even the whole quid pro quo
thing the worst moment of the presser
had to do with the fact that the Trump
administration awarded next year's g7
the summit of world leaders to his own
resort to president Trump's resort now I
am so annoyed by this I cannot even tell
you annoyed irritated even if you think
that it's not corrupt it is the absolute
appearance of corruption it's the
absolute appearance of corruption right
Trump's people are claiming that is not
in emoluments violation is not a
emoluments are basically bribery that's
not in the president enriching himself
they say well he won't make any profit
off of this it's just he really really
really likes the resort okay this is
where Trump's people do him a deep
disserve us and Trump does himself a
deep to service his people should be
saying to him mr. president you've made
a whole thing out of Joe Biden appearing
to be corrupt with Hunter and now you
are directing the g7 to be held at your
own resort that you own that costs
millions and millions of dollars that
that event you're directing it to your
own resort don't you think that creates
the appearance of impropriety why do you
think this is smart now Trump because he
has never met I mean Trump Trump is like
my three-year-old when it comes to
reverse psychology like if you want from
to do something you tell them you don't
want to do it so maybe the best thing
that should have happened here is that
all of his age Peter said best idea you
ever had mr. president you should
totally ignore the the implications of
corruption you should totally hold it at
Doral and then from be like I don't want
to do it anymore but the fact is that
everybody around Trump unfortunately is
afraid of Trump and nobody apparently
had the balls to just say to him
straight out mr. president it looks
really bad when you are directing giant
events to your own resorts in the middle
of the presidency it looks as though
you're exerting the pressure of the
presidency in order to raise money for
your own businesses I mean it does it
looks bad there's no other way to put it
it looks bad it looks corrupt it looks
bad now is it corrupt or bad well you
have to show that the money flows you'd
have to show that Trump made some sort
of profit from it but a
the president's desire to show off his
own properties and his desire to talk
about how wonderful his own properties
are it is not good for him it is not
good for his administration it is stupid
and it is wrong and so according to the
Washington Post it Trump has awarded the
2020 group of seven summit for world
leaders to his private company
scheduling the summit for June at his
Trump national Doral Miami Golf Resort
in Florida the White House announced on
Thursday
Trump's Doral resort has been in sharp
decline in recent years its net
operating income fell 69 percent from
2015 to 2017 a Trump organization
representative testified last year the
reason was Trump's damaged brand now the
g7 summit will draw hundreds of
diplomats journalists and security
personnel to the resort during one of
its slowest months of the year when
Miami is hot and the hotel is often less
than 40 percent full it will also
provide a worldwide spotlight for the
club
apparently Trump asked his aides earlier
this year what about d'Oro Mulvaney's
had a nationwide search conducted by
trump's administration led to the
conclusion that the president was right
Doral was far and away the best physical
facility for the meeting is what Mulaney
said weird we're the best physical
facility in the United States anywhere
in the United States for the meeting
happens to be owned by the President of
the United States
okay I'm sorry this is absurd it's
absurd and it's just in again it's it's
everybody around Trump trying to stroke
his ego because they feel like if they
stroke his ego maybe he'll give them
some of their policy priorities and it's
a huge mistake somebody should have just
said to him no somebody should have said
to him no but nobody will say to him no
and it damages him like if you're
working for Trump to be reelected this
kind of stuff is very very bad for him
and somebody needs to say no to him it's
just it's absurd Mulvaney didn't say
what the other sites were just that they
were all worse just this was the best it
was the most unbelievable okay
Trump said in 2016 I will be leaving my
great business in total of course after
he was elected and yet we have seen that
that it is not true that he is not
directing business to his own businesses
now maybe he doesn't make money from
that but this is like it's it's absurd
I'm sorry it's just absurd on a
political level it is it is on a moral
level it's absurd like there's just no
rationale for it Mulvaney was asked
about this here's what Maldini had to
say he's not making any money off of
this just like he's not making any money
from working here and
if you think it's gonna help his brand
that's great but I would suggest that he
probably doesn't need much help
promoting his brand so put the profit
one aside and deal with a perfect place
I mean who was here for the last time
was a Camp David was that the perfect
place in fact I understand the folks who
participate in it hated it and thought
it was a miserable place to have the
g-seven it was way too small it was way
to promote my understanding this media
didn't like it because you had to drive
an hour and a bus to get there either
way
okay so Camp David was dead but but
apparently like last I checked it turns
out that there like lots of hotels and
resorts in the United States lots of
them I've been to summits and meetings
with very high-level people at resorts
that are not in fact a draw and there
are quite nice like mo veiny admitted he
was skeptical to the plan at first but
he called jor-el the perfect physical
look at the perfect physical location
perfect Miami in the middle of July
perfect and dismiss criticisms by saying
Trump is the most recognizable name in
the English language and probably around
the world right now so he doesn't need
help with marketing he said there's no
profit here clearly there is profit with
the Biden's if you look at the
difference between the Trump family and
the Biden family the Trump family made
their money before they went into
politics oh my god if you're making the
comparison between Trump and Biden and
your entire criticism of Biden is that
he appeared to be using the power of his
office to benefit his son and this is an
appearances question appearances like
helloo helloo appearances he's his mic
on I so that was that was really grand
for Mick Mulvaney well we will get to
more of this in just one second we'll
also get to the 2020 Democratic crisis
and what I think was actually a really
important speech by Mark Zuckerberg over
at Facebook yesterday but first you need
to go over to daily wire calm folks the
daily wires long-awaited app is finally
here and it truly is phenomenal
first-rate if you're a subscriber you
can access all of our content including
articles shows and more straight from
the app all access subscribers get our
new and exclusive discussion features
where they can interact directly with
hosts writers and other special guests
the app is available on Apple and
Android download today become a
subscriber and come and join the fun a
little bit later on in the show we have
two additional hours of the show every
day you can access all three hours of
the show when you subscribe so if you
love the show but you want more of it
well good news for you you can now watch
all three hours of the show and you can
be part of the mailbag we're probably
not gonna have time for the mailbag on
the podcast today but we'll do it later
on the radio show so if your subscriber
you get those questions answered go
check us out over at Daley
calmly are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
okay so a little bit more on this
Ukraine stuff and then we will move on
to what I think was actually a pretty
important moment over at Georgetown
yesterday because people will get into
that in just one second but first
there's one final story that we have to
take note of with regard to all of
Ukrainian fugitives great Corinth route
19 talked and that is Gordon sunland who
is the Trump EU ambassador he told house
investigators that he opposed the
president's request to run Ukraine
policy through Rudy Giuliani again for
the 1,000th time this is all gonna come
down to Rudy Giuliani not Mick Mulvaney
it's gonna come down to Rudy Giuliani
and whether Rudy Giuliani was in fact
just giving the president bad
information or whether he and Trump were
scheming to go get Democrats whether
they were like Elmer Fudd on a rabbit
hunt or whether they were just being fed
bad information about something that is
of public interest in the United States
namely how the 2016 election was
affected by foreign interference okay
meanwhile the there was a big speech
that was that was done by Mark
Zuckerberg yesterday at Georgetown now
quit preface here there's a story that
came out a little bit earlier this week
in Politico and the story suggested that
I have met with Mark Zuckerberg now let
me say clearly and for the record I will
never tell the media who I meet with
ever I'm not gonna tell them who I meet
with I'm not gonna tell them what we say
the reason is because you know in my job
and what I do I talk with a wide variety
of extraordinarily powerful people that
the left would not want me talking with
the left spends an enormous amount of
time trying to shut down precisely those
conversations by reporting that the
conversations happen and then bringing
outside pressure to bear to stop people
from having those discussions in the
first place I talk with lots of people
they don't want me talking with because
I think the conversation is important I
think that persuasion is important I
think it's important to talk with people
you disagree with and so my answer to
people who are asking me about meeting
with Mark Zuckerberg or anybody else for
that matter in a position of power is
take a hike son because guess what I
meet with lots of people it's none of
your business
and it's particularly non your business
because the goal of so many people on
the left is you stop exactly the sorts
of conversation to make the country
better those conversations make the
country better the goal of the left is
to prevent those conversations which in
fact is the entire issue that is
happening right now with regard to
Facebook so listen I understand
conservative skepticism about Facebook I
really do okay I've criticized Facebook
copious
in the past when Facebook has taken
action to kick people I don't even like
off of Facebook but I think that
Facebook has been too stringent in their
interpretation of their own quote
unquote hate speech policy which I think
by the way is a stupid policy I think
that the Facebook hate speech policy is
idiotic because there is no actual
definition of hate speech but let's be
clear the real pressure that is being
brought to bear right now on Facebook is
being brought by the left and the reason
the left is trying to bring pressure on
Facebook is because Donald Trump won in
2016 it is that simple the left doesn't
like the Trump one the left doesn't like
that you have an alternative method of
getting your news because Facebook
allows the free flow of information more
or less now the more or less is a
serious question and a question we have
to deal with but the fact is I over at
say Lee Weyer can't exactly complain
about Facebook's dissemination of news
considering that we get an enormous
amount of traffic via Facebook and so to
enum a number of other conservative
publishers if it were not for social
media sites like Facebook if it were not
for social media sites like Instagram if
it were not for social media sites like
YouTube it would be very difficult for
you to get information the social media
sites have been very useful in ending
around the media which by the way is why
the media are so all-fired pissed off at
Facebook it's why the Democrats are so
all-fired pissed off at Facebook is why
you're seeing elizabeth warren
threatening to break up facebook and
other big tech companies not because
they're worried about monopoly of
information but because they want to
restore the monopoly of information
understand that social media platforms i
may disagree with their rules i may
disagree about the implementation of the
rules i may be quite skeptical of the
people who are in charge of actually
making those rules apply but if i have a
choice between a world where social
media allows me to get information from
a variety of sources across the
political spectrum and a world where the
only newspapers i can buy at the
newsstand are the New York Times the LA
Times and The Washington Post that is
not a choice for the journalists it's
not a choice either which is why they
hate the big tech they hate the social
media platforms and you're starting to
see all of these journalists journalism
in all over the place
what they would prefer is an area of
limited information but they would
prefer limited information and that's
why you see the New York Times today
running a piece called from Matt Stoller
called tech companies are destroying a
democracy and freedom of the press
destroying it as opposed to the New York
Times which just spread its own brand of
news
without any challengers in the space
because there was no alternative means
of distribution right so the New York
Times is running full pieces now by
these books you have people like Kara
Swisher who is extremely cents aureus by
Nature
who is calling for her to be one of the
controllers of Facebook's new sort of
judiciary board that would help rule on
whether things have violated policy she
would like to do that because switcher
happens to be censorious right folks on
the left want control of the means of
the distribution of information in any
case mark zuckerberg gave a speech to
Georgetown and it actually was quite an
important speech because he is actually
kicking back against in my opinion at
the left he's actually kicking back
against a lot of censorious people I'm
left now do I trust Zuckerberg and
Facebook to make all the right decisions
about this stuff no which is why I think
that we ought to cast a very hardened
eye at exactly what Facebook and the
social media platforms do in the
interpretation of their vague and
ridiculous hate speech policies but at
least Zuckerberg seems to understand
some of the problems so he gives the
speech to Georgetown the media go nuts
it's terrible we need to break up
Facebook Facebook why would you trust
anything the New York Times or The
Washington Post are telling you if they
tell you when it comes to what's good
for freedom of speech is that Facebook
be shut down why would you trust the
people who want a restoration of the
monopoly of informational flow why would
you trust them like I'm seeing
conservatives who are like yeah
Washington Post in New York Times right
in no other context would you say this
none but suddenly you're saying this
because there's some people on the right
who make a good living ripping on big
tech without actually understanding all
the issues in any case Zuckerberg the
Zuckerberg I gave honestly I thought his
speech was was pretty solid yesterday
over at Georgetown here's what he had to
say about the value of free speech our
commitment to each other
that we hold each other's right to
express ourselves and be heard above our
own desire to always get our way in
every debate that's how we make progress
together but this view is is
increasingly being challenged now some
people believe that giving more people a
voice is driving division rather than
bringing people together more people
across the spectrum believe that
achieving the political outcomes that
they think matter is more important
and every person having a voice in being
heard and I think that that's dangerous
this is 100 percent right okay at least
on this point
Zuckerberg seems to get it right he's
saying that there are people on the Left
who want to shut down he doesn't say the
left obviously his he's not gonna get
partisan with this but Reid it's the
last okay there are people on the Left
who want to shut down certain voices and
he even gets that they're doing it by
broadening the Mandate of violence by
suggesting that speech is violence right
here Zuckerberg said in the middle of
the species that people no longer have
to rely on traditional gatekeepers in
politics or media to make their voices
heard and that has important
consequences I understand the concerns
about how tech platforms have
centralized power but I actually believe
the much bigger story is how much these
platforms have decentralized power by
putting it directly into people's hands
you can't argue with the reality of that
that is 100% true before the barrier to
entry in the media marketplace was
spending a hundred million dollars on
the New York Times
now the barrier to entry is setting up a
Facebook page that's a pretty major
major difference and he talks about the
the trend toward pulling back on free
expression he says we want the progress
that comes from free expression but not
the tension okay that is that is exactly
right right he he says it's hard to get
the area of hate speech right I think
it's not as hard to get the area of hate
speech right I just think that the the
general notion of hate speech ought to
go away if you are involved in inciting
violence that should enlist our
controlling policy at Facebook I would
be recommending a fulsome First
Amendment standard which means unless
you are actually inciting violence
unless you are actually engaging in
violation of law I would not ban you
from Facebook I would not denigrate your
face but he's the one with the the
private company and they're not in fact
a government outlet with that said he is
correct in his basic understanding of
the issue right so for example unlike
the NBA unlike a lot of people on the on
the corporate left he has refused to do
business with China he said he wanted to
have service with China but his
principles with regard to what Facebook
should be did not jive with what China
was doing so that's very different from
what Google has been doing Google's just
going over there and willy-nilly making
deals and changing source results for
the Chinese Zuckerberg didn't do that so
at least give him credit where credit is
due I wanted our services in China
because I believe in connecting the
whole
and I thought you know maybe we could
help create a more open society and this
isn't that I worked hard on for a long
time but we could never come to
agreement on what it would take for us
to operate there and they never let us
in and now we have more freedom to speak
out and stand up for the values that we
believe in and fight for free expression
around the world okay he's getting this
right like I don't know if you're on the
right you're ripping into his speech
today like it's cuz he didn't listen to
his Beach right here Zuckerberg clip
floor hit this clip he talks about what
he thinks his responsibility is now
again how he actually carries out that
responsibility is something that we
should all have our eye on we should
like everyone should be very skeptical
of people in positions of power carrying
out their responsibilities properly but
Zuckerberg at least seems to pay lip
service to what he understands the
responsibility to be right here right
mean listen to that what he's saying
here is no different than what I would
say it is not okay here is it know how
he carries it out may be very different
and that remains a question that we
should all keep our eye on as I keep
saying here here's Zuckerberg clip 4 I
believe that we have two
responsibilities to remove content when
it can cause real danger as effectively
as we can and to fight to uphold as wide
of a definition of freedom of expression
as possible and to not allow the
definition of what is considered
dangerous
to expand beyond what is absolutely
necessary and that's what I'm committed
to okay good good I mean okay so now
hold them to his word now hold them to
his word but the reason the media are so
all-fired pissed with Mark Zuckerberg
and with Facebook is because he is
saying stuff like this because
Zuckerberg actually his Zuckerberg like
a lot of these big tech platforms unlike
Google which apparently just wants to
make money in China
Zuckerberg is actually paying
lip-service again we'll see how it
carries out in practice he's paying lip
service to First Amendment values right
there he is and if the right has any
brains at all they should be cheering
what Zuckerberg said yesterday about
limiting the left's tempt to conflate
speech with violence and broaden the
definition of violence to encompass
anything they disagree with the
Zuckerberg was pushing back against that
yesterday and who do you want it do you
really want listen I mean not trust Mark
Zuckerberg to set the standards frankly
I'm not sure that Zuckerberg from his
own speech trust Mark Zuckerberg to set
the standards I don't think
should be trusted to set the standards
per se but who do you trust more private
industry which is at least responsive to
the public or the government which does
not give a damn and is controlled by
open political partisans because those
are your two choices okay time for a
quick thing I like and then a quick
thing that I hate so things that I like
South Park they are the most brilliant
satirist out there they remain most
brilliant satirist out there and they
did a bit
mocking LeBron James and it is pretty
spectacular like by the way quick note
the same media that feel uncomfortable
like sort of uncomfortable criticizing
LeBron James over completely cows
heading to China have no problem talking
about breaking up big and breaking up
it's kind of crazy and that is Cartman
directly quoting LeBron yes we are still
allowed thank God at least for the time
being to make fun of people in positions
of public of public power okay time for
a very quick thing that I hate this is
just spectacular I'm not sure I love it
or whether I hate it it is spectacular
so there's a BuzzFeed reporter her name
is Katherine Miller and she was tweeting
out about the 2020 Democratic
presidential debate and she tweeted out
quote hard to know if last night harmed
or helped warn but I think we can all
come together and agree a debate
highlight was warren telling Kamala
Harris know about banning Trump from
Twitter and then continuing with her
points in the manner of shrugging off a
Greenpeace clip board person and so that
that is what Miller tweeted and by the
way she's right it was hilarious Kamala
Harris was so desperate for attention I
mean there the entire debate we just
like love babe what will you pay
attention
Twitter me that she thought that her
best hit on Elizabeth Warren was not you
called yourself a Native American for 30
years on official forums her bus attack
instead was why won't you ban Trump from
Twitter man like that how my hearse is
very bad so commonly Harris's campaign
spokesperson then the Harris aide anyway
Harris aide then sends this insane in
the same note to Katherine Miller quote
hey I have talked to her directly a few
times when she's tweeted out she sent
this to apparently Ben Smith I guess the
the editor-in-chief of buzz he hey I've
talked her directly a few times when
she's tweeted out stuff like this and I
told her I was glad she deleted at this
tweet she deleted the tweet there's
nothing inappropriate about the tweet
but this kind of stuff is just really a
horrible look for you guys
frankly it's whiteness manifest weight
this manifest what in what in what in
that tweet has anything to do with race
it just says that Harris is a crazy
person who stands outside the
supermarket with a Greenpeace clipboard
that's a hundred percent correct and it
has nothing to do with race I know
Greenpeace activists they come in all
races and sizes and sexual orientations
at least they appear to so like what if
Kamala Harris's people are running to
that sort of racism to call her a
Greenpeace activist pretty weird as if
Kamala shrugged off a Warren critique of
how she wasn't with her on Facebook we'd
get raped and she would get Loudoun is
taking on corporate power the blithe
mockery here of Kamala while Loudoun
Warren style is just not up to par I say
this to you to be super frank and
because I really like your guys's work
the platform and your reporters we work
well together across the board but this
is a bit problematic there's that we're
gonna problematic so problem it okay you
can't name what's wrong with it but it's
problematic also I love the tacit
admission right there that we work well
together across the board guys and if
you just have your people delete their
tweets we can continue to work really
well together and be bestest of friends
that's not corrupt in any way shape or
form
well done Kamala Harris esteem trying
too hard trying too hard
and by the way points to Ben Smith you
responded quote do you seriously not
have real problems this text makes you
think you are totally totally unready
for an actual presidential campaign
oh is that rare point it's that rare
time of the day when I am praising Ben
Smith been right on the money man yes
correct more of this more of this please
love that just spectacular spectacular
stuff amazing okay we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content there was so much we weren't
able to get to on the show because it
was an action pack today today but if
you want more including the mailbag head
on over to daily wire.com and subscribe
and we will see you there later I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo why douse key
edited by Adam sy events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Joshua alvera production assistant Nick
see him the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
19 on the Matt Walsh show we're not just
discussing politics we're talking
culture faith family all the things that
are really important to you so come join
the conversation